et puis la situation en libye est
toujours au point mort entre le
gouvernement du premier ministre fayyad
elle sa rage et l'armée nationale
libyenne du maréchal haftar depuis
plusieurs semaines turquie soutient
militairement le gouvernement de fayez
sara a stoppé l'avancée des forces daft
art en egypte les députés ont donné le
20 juillet dernier au président abdel
fattah al-sisi le feu vert pour une
possible intervention militaire en libye
si les forces du gouvernement d'union
nationale avance vers l'est du pays près
de la frontière égyptienne où règnent
les forces du maréchal haftar et dans ce
contexte l'algérie s'est positionné pour
une résolution pacifique du conflit
je vous propose d'écouter sabri
boukadoum le ministre algérien des
affaires étrangères
nous appelons toutes les parties
prenantes du conflit libyen à
reconnaître la nécessité d'un règlement
politique dans le pays
c'est en cela que réside la vision de
l'algérie
l'initiative algérienne ne diffèrent pas
des principes de la conférence de berlin
qui a réuni de nombreuses parties
prenantes y compris notre pays pour le
moment on peut dire qu'aucune partie ne
s'oppose à cette vision algérienne de
leur résolution de la crise libyenne ali
non j'estime qu'il ya une possibilité de
convergence des positions et des points
de vue des parties ainsi que d'un cessez
le feu en libye
les positions de l'algérie de l'egypte
et de la tunisie ont beaucoup en commun
fiable
nous sommes conscients de tous les défis
qui constitue une menace pour la
sécurité nationale de tous les voisins
de la libye et de l'algérie
la situation compliquée en libye a
entraîné des complications même malik
qui est assez éloigné de la libre cela
dit nous saluons sa participation à la
résolution de cette crise d'ailleurs
dans ce contexte il faut dire que tous
les pays voisins ont soutenu la
prochaine j'ai rien au règlement en
libye
elle se base sur un principe le premier
temps la résolution pacifique de la
crise et l'abandon de l'option militaire
film le deuxième étant celui du cessez
le feu et le troisième de la négociation
à cet égard nous sommes certainement
opposée à toute ingérence militaire et
lançons un appel pour le respect de
l'embargo sur les armes en libye qui est
toujours en vigueur
les relations franco algériennes sont
marqués par leur caractère particulier
ce sont des relations historiques
remplie de souvenirs ayant de
l'importance particulière pour l'algérie
en outre la diaspora algérienne en
france et très nombreuses par ailleurs
nous sommes pays riverains de la
méditerranée qui ne nous sépare pas mais
au contraire nous relie nos liens
économiques sont très forts et tout
comme dans nos relations avec la russie
nous comptons sur la coopération
équitable et le respect mutuel des
institutions étatiques et des choix
politiques